[Music]
it's one of the most recognizable
and most visited landmarks in america
but mount rushmore has a secret
the sculpture which famously depicts
four former u.s presidents as 60-foot
granite faces
was constructed between 1927 and 1941
under the direction of architect gutson
borglum everybody knows that
but few people know about the secret
project borglum was working on
as part of the monument let's find out
[Music]
why
freedom hope justice south dakota's
beloved national memorial mount rushmore
is a testament to these deeply cherished
american values
justice tell that to the indians they
stole the land from
uh let's keep it nice you got it kimo
sabe by the 1920s south dakota now a u.s
state
had become a popular road trip
destination for americans they drove in
to see the newly designed black hills
national forest
and wild cave national park governor
peter norvik had also built the needles
highway a scenic route winding through
the granite formations of the black
hills
but dawn robinson a historian at the
south dakota state historical society
believed the state needed a little
something more to entice tourists
in 1924 he learned about an attempt to
carve the likenesses of confederate
leaders into the side of stone mountain
in georgia
so robinson launched a campaign to
create south dakota's
own monument robinson envisioned sort of
an ode to the old west
with historic figures like lewis and
clark and lakota leader red cloud
he reached out to stone mountain
sculptor gutson borglum to transform the
granite mountain into what it is today
borglum became famous for sculptures
honoring us history he was also famous
for his flamboyant
and bombastic personality in georgia he
became involved with the stone mountain
project but soon began to clash with
stone mountain memorial association
and in february 1925 the association
fired borglum
citing mismanagement of funds and his
offensive egotism and his delusions of
grandeur
borglum made national news when he
destroyed the stone mountain models
and fled the state that sounds perfect
for a government project
borglum was talked into working on mount
rushmore because it was a chance
at immortality and he liked the sound of
that so over the next 16 years
borglum wrestled with the federal
government over funding and control of
mount rushmore which
he technically never completed borglum
wanted to carve the presidents down to
their wastes
and chisel a description of the memorial
next to them but when it became clear
that there wasn't enough space for
an inscription or a lot of this stuff he
came up
with a new idea he envisioned a grand
hall measuring 80 feet tall and 100 feet
long
accessible via an 800 foot granite
staircase
that would include busts of famous
americans as well as bronze and glass
cabinets containing historical documents
like the constitution
the bill of rights declaration of
independence and a massive bronze eagle
with a 38-foot wingspan would be mounted
above the entrance
with the inscription reading the hall of
records now borglum believed that future
generations
might find mount rushmore as much a
mystery as stonehenge or the pyramids of
egypt so he wanted to come up with a way
to preserve its history
and make sure the story behind the
carving would never be forgotten
so the vault was built to be just behind
abraham lincoln's hairline
and would contain all the information
anyone would ever need to know about the
mountain well
wait so they would have to blow a hole
in lincoln's head to do this
yeah and nobody saw a problem with that
you know i never really thought of that
sick semper tyrannis work on the hall of
records began in july 1938 but was
halted a year later
congress wanted construction to focus on
the president's first
before moving on to the hall everyone's
got a side project
i know hey you want to read my
screenplay
no despite what congress said borglum
he went ahead with the project anyway
the onset of world war ii in 1941 slowed
down the vault project
they only got as far as a 70-foot cavern
blasted into the mountain
and borglum was still refining the
presidents when his health began to
deteriorate
he died on march 6 1941 leaving his son
lincoln to continue the work
but the project kept running into
problems for example
jefferson's head couldn't be completed
due to the quality of the stone
in fact jefferson was originally
supposed to be on washington's right
side but the stone was too weak so
they kind of improvised as they went
along now eventually funding ran out and
the project was declared
final and complete on october 31st
1941 finished yep finished
the statues are incomplete the
inscription was never started
and the rock that was blasted out of the
mountain is still lying in a huge pile
at the site well they said it was good
enough it sounds like a government-run
project
so for over 50 years the hall of records
was just
a hole in lincoln's head right but for
decades borglum's descendants
petitioned the government to complete
the room in honor of his work and
finally in 1998
officials agreed to a scaled-back
version of the idea
today sculpted into a series of
porcelain enamel panels is the story and
history of mount rushmore along with an
explanation of why washington
jefferson roosevelt and lincoln were
chosen there are also panels sculpted
with the text of the u.s constitution
the bill of rights the declaration of
independence and the gettysburg address
park officials even included a biography
of borglum they're all kept inside a
titanium vault behind a giant
1200 pound granite slab now the hall of
records
is not open to the public strict
security measures have been put in place
following a breach by greenpeace who
hung a banner
reading stop global warming over the
monument in 2009.
what does mount rushmore have to do with
global warming uh
i honestly have no idea even high
ranking officials in the government are
banned from seeing this hidden
and largely unknown chamber but its true
intent was to serve as a historical
record for future civilization
so we can imagine that borglum would be
pleased to know that his project was
finally completed
and may one day do exactly what he
intended
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's cyclefish this has
been the y-files
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you
are appreciated
[Music]
you